Anything that takes, if you're in range land in C++ 20 or 23, a range and turns it into a range of ranges. Or if you're in sequence land in Swift, a sequence into a sequence of sequences. Or if you're in Haskell land and you take a list and you got a list of lists. Or a string and you now have a list of strings. Anything that does that, I consider a cut. And there are four or five different types of cuts. There are index cuts, predicate cuts, function cuts, and then the last one is what I call FHM, frequency hash map cuts. There are index cuts, predicate cuts, function cuts, and then the last one is what I call FHM, frequency hash map cuts.
任何在C++ 20或23的范围（range）领域中，将一个范围转换为范围的范围的操作；或者在Swift的序列（sequence）领域中，将一个序列转换为序列的序列；又或者在Haskell领域中，将一个列表转换为列表的列表，或者将一个字符串转换为字符串列表的操作，我都将其视为“切割”（cut）。切割有四五种不同的类型：索引切割、谓词切割、函数切割，最后一种是我称之为FHM（频率哈希映射）切割。
Welcome to ADSP, the podcast episode 173, recorded on March 6, 2024. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host, Bryce, we chat about the category of algorithms called cuts and how to implement a parallel chunk buy. This is what? Episode 173. No, no, no, no, no, no, no. Episode 173, because this is what just happened, folks. We had a 30-minute episode on Bryce's apartment and couches.
欢迎收听ADSP播客第173期，录制于2024年3月6日。我是Connor，今天我和我的联合主持人Bryce一起聊聊被称为“切割”的算法类别，以及如何实现并行分块（chunk by）。这是第几期？第173期。不，不，不，不，不，不，不。第173期，因为刚才发生了一件事，伙计们。我们录了一期关于Bryce公寓和沙发的30分钟节目。
This will air. It was just on couches. We didn't even really talk about it. We talked about the fixtures, the brushed brass. We'll send pictures of the apartment. But you're not going to hear that episode. So actually, this is episode 172. That episode's probably going to be like 170, late high numbers, 180,
这期节目会播出的。内容全是关于沙发的。我们甚至没怎么聊正题。我们聊了固定装置、拉丝黄铜。我们会发公寓的照片。但你们听不到那期节目。所以实际上，这是第172期。那期节目大概会排在170左右，或者180左右的高位。
because we're going to record this algorithm episode right now. We're in Bryce's apartment. I'm visiting for the New York C++ meetup tomorrow night. We just had sushi last night at Sugarfish with Sean Parent of Adobe. And we went to a very mediocre comedy show. And we went to a very mediocre comedy show. Shout out to the – actually, we're not going to shout it out because we don't want to make him feel bad. But we went to a – You know who you we don't want to make him feel bad.
因为我们现在要录这期算法节目。我们在Bryce的公寓里。我明天晚上要参加纽约的C++聚会。昨晚我们和Adobe的Sean Parent在Sugarfish吃了寿司。然后我们去看了场非常平庸的喜剧表演。我们去看了场非常平庸的喜剧表演。向那个——其实我们就不点名了，因为不想让他难堪。但我们去了一个——你知道我们不想让他难堪。
You know who you are. Yeah, you know who you are. And if you're from New York and you're familiar with the comedy club scene, they had mini donuts and the mini donuts were the best part of the show. We love them, folks. We love them. Anyways, the couch episode and the apartment episode isn't going to come up for a few episodes. Why is that? Because we're going to do the algorithm episode right now. That's going to air in like two days on March 8th. That'll be episode 172. Then we're going to be recording with Sean Parent live, I think at Adobe headquarters, not headquarters, at the New York Adobe offices. Adobe HQ is back where Sean lives in San Jose or outside San Jose. I mean, the HQ is in San Jose. Sean doesn't live in San Jose. Anyways, trying not to dock Sean here, but he lives near San Jose. Anyways, and so we're going to do probably a one-part or two-part episode with Sean.
你知道你是谁。是的，你知道你是谁。如果你来自纽约，熟悉喜剧俱乐部场景，他们有迷你甜甜圈，迷你甜甜圈是演出中最棒的部分。我们爱死它们了，伙计们。我们爱死它们了。总之，沙发那期和公寓那期节目还要过几期才会播出。为什么？因为我们现在要录算法这期。这期大概会在两天后的3月8日播出。那将是第172期。然后我们要和Sean Parent现场录音，我想是在Adobe总部，不，不是总部，是在纽约的Adobe办公室。Adobe总部在Sean住的圣何塞或圣何塞郊外。我是说，总部在圣何塞。Sean不住在圣何塞。总之，尽量不泄露Sean的隐私，但他住在圣何塞附近。总之，我们要和Sean录一期或两期节目。
That's going to be episode 173, 174. And then maybe we'll save the couch episode for when we run low and we need like a backup one. And then that's when it'll air. So maybe it might not even be until like the 220s. Who knows? Also, folks, it's been about what, six, seven episodes in a row where we haven't had a guest? That's not for lack of trying.
那将是第173、174期。然后也许我们会把沙发那期留到我们存货不足、需要备份的时候再播。到那时才会播出。所以可能要到220多期才播。谁知道呢？还有，伙计们，这已经是连续六七期没有嘉宾了吧？这可不是因为我们没努力。
It's Connor's fault. We now have a DuckDB individual who we actually haven't confirmed the time yet. I think, Connor, I think you should not announce guests until we have the recording of the guests. Nope, they're coming on. They said they'd be willing. We just haven't set up the final time. We haven't even had it scheduled.
是Connor的错。我们现在有一位DuckDB的人，但我们还没确认时间。我想，Connor，我觉得你不应该在确认录音时间之前就宣布嘉宾。不，他们会来的。他们说愿意。只是我们还没定下最终时间。我们甚至还没安排好。
And we have who reached out. We said if you are listening or if one of your friends is listening. We haven't even scheduled it. We haven't scheduled it. It's going to happen, though. Did he write us back? He did. And then did I reply with times?
还有我们联系过的人。我们说过如果你在听，或者你的朋友在听。我们甚至还没安排。我们还没安排。但这一定会发生的。他回信了吗？回了。然后我回复时间了吗？
He did. Not with times. He did write us back, though. Anyways, name him. We're going to have Doug Greger on this podcast. We're going to have Doug Greger on. So we've got a couple different people, and we've got Sean coming up. So don't worry.
他回了。不是回复时间。但他确实回信了。总之，说出他的名字吧。我们要请Doug Greger上这个播客。我们要请Doug Greger。所以我们有几位不同的人选，还有Sean要来。所以别担心。
If you're tired of these mano-a-mano with your two co-hosts in 2024, don't worry. We're fixing it. And now, after four minutes of preamble, we're going to talk about— You're thinking about grouping operations wrong. I've just been waiting to pounce. I've just been sitting here waiting to pounce on Connor for an hour. Let's do a brief overview of what a grouping operation is. Because I call them, I actually have a new category name for them.
如果你厌倦了2024年只有我们两个联合主持人面对面，别担心。我们正在解决这个问题。现在，经过四分钟的开场白，我们要谈谈——你对分组操作的理解是错误的。我一直等着反击呢。我坐在这儿等了一个小时，就为了反击Connor。让我们简要概述一下什么是分组操作。因为我称它们为——我其实给它们起了一个新的类别名称。
They're called cut operations, not grouping. You do the brief overview and then you tell me when I can fire this loaded gun. Here's a 120-second overview. It's brief. There's this new – I mean, we've talked about these lots. Here's a few examples. Chunk buy, splits, chunks, et cetera. Anything that takes, if you're in range land in C++ 20 or 23, a range and turns it into a range of ranges.
它们被称为切割操作，而不是分组。你做简要概述，然后告诉我什么时候可以开火。这是一个120秒的概述。很简短。有这个新的——我是说，我们谈过很多次了。这里有几个例子。Chunk by、splits、chunks等等。任何在C++ 20或23的范围领域中，将一个范围转换为范围的范围的操作。
Or if you're in sequence land in Swift, a sequence into a sequence of sequences, or if you're in Haskell land and you take a list and you got a list of lists, or a string and you now have a list of strings. Anything that does that, I consider a cut. And there are four or five different types of cuts. There are index cuts, predicate cuts, function cuts, and then the last one is what I call FHM, frequency hash map cuts. And technically when it comes to predicate cuts, there's different types, unary and binary predicates. Anyways, if Bryce is curious of the different types of cuts, we can get into it. But basically anything that chunks or dices things up, there you go.
或者在Swift的序列领域中，将一个序列转换为序列的序列；或者在Haskell领域中，将一个列表转换为列表的列表，或者将一个字符串转换为字符串列表。任何做这些操作的，我都认为是切割。切割有四五种类型。有索引切割、谓词切割、函数切割，最后一种是我称之为FHM（频率哈希映射）切割。严格来说，谓词切割还有不同类型，一元和二元谓词。总之，如果Bryce对不同类型的切割感到好奇，我们可以深入探讨。但基本上任何分块或切割东西的操作，就是这样。
All right. So a little more context, Connor. And by the way, that was only 50 seconds. I've been trying to work on not rambling as much because I've gotten some feedback from people that I just – remember that one time you asked for me to describe – No, don't care. Shut up and listen to me. Okay, a little bit of context.
好了。那么，再多一点背景，Connor。顺便说一句，那才50秒。我一直在努力减少废话，因为有人反馈说我总是——还记得有一次你让我描述——不，不在乎。闭嘴听我说。好吧，一点背景。
I've been working on a project to figure out how to paralyze C++ ranges, in particular how to deal with range adapters in ranges that we might want to paralyze in C++ recently. And some of the tricky ones to deal with are the grouping operations like chunk by and split. Now, Connor. And so Connor and I have been talking about this a bit during the day. And so you, the listener, may not have all the context here. I don't care. And we love that because, you know, it's been four years since I've been in an office next to someone where you get to chat about work while working.
我一直在做一个项目，研究如何并行化C++范围，特别是如何处理我们最近在C++中可能想要并行化的范围适配器。其中一些比较棘手的是像chunk by和split这样的分组操作。现在，Connor。我和Connor白天一直在讨论这个问题。所以你，听众，可能没有全部背景。我不在乎。我们喜欢这样，因为你知道，我已经四年没在办公室和人并排坐着，边工作边聊天了。
I mean, you did give me today – you either – well, I think you later said that you didn't come up with the clever idea. But you certainly – I got you half – I started you halfway there and then you made an insight on top of my insight. Well, I'm sure we'll do an episode about that. So here's the thing about grouping operations. You, I think, are thinking about them wrong. Because earlier you made a comment that they are not removal operations, that they are not like filtering operations. Some of them are. Some of them aren't.
我是说，你今天确实给了我——你要么——好吧，我想你后来又说那不是你想出的聪明主意。但你确实——你让我完成了一半——我让你走了一半路，然后你在我的见解之上又有了新的见解。好吧，我相信我们会专门做一期节目来谈这个。所以关于分组操作是这样的。我觉得你对它们的理解是错误的。因为早些时候你评论说它们不是移除操作，它们不像过滤操作。有些是。有些不是。
You started mansplaining to me chunk buy. First of all, can you mansplain to a man? Yeah, you can. Can you? Yeah. That's a whole other episode right there. Dude, we're not tangenting now. Make your argument. What? You were claiming that chunk buy is not in our removal operation. Oh, chunk buy is definitely not. So I have a table inside my Jell-O project where I categorize these
你开始向我解释chunk by了。首先，你可以向一个男人解释吗？是的，可以。真的吗？是的。那是另一期节目的内容了。伙计，我们现在不跑题。提出你的论点。什么？你声称chunk by不是移除操作。哦，chunk by绝对不是。所以我的Jell-O项目里有一个表格，我把这些
types of cuts. And there is a similar to that algorithm table that I had back in C++ now, 2019's algorithm intuition, where you've got reduce, scan, etc. And then some of them are maps versus reduces. Some of them look at one indexes versus two indexes, etc. This table, one of the columns, that's a binary column, it's either yes or no, is does it drop elements? And chunkby does not drop elements. It doesn't drop elements, yes. It doesn't drop anything. Okay, but you're thinking about it wrong for the purposes of
类型的切割进行了分类。这类似于我在2019年C++ Now的算法直觉演讲中提到的那个算法表，你有reduce、scan等等。其中一些是map与reduce的区别。有些看一个索引，有些看两个索引等等。这个表，其中一列是二进制列，要么是，要么否，就是它是否会丢弃元素？而chunk by不会丢弃元素。它不丢弃元素，是的。它什么都不丢弃。好吧，但为了
parallelism. Okay, the way that we tackle almost any parallel programming challenge is the first thing we do is work distribution. We take our input and we come up with some strategy for how we're going to distribute it among a group of threads.
并行化的目的，你对它的理解是错误的。好吧，我们处理几乎任何并行编程挑战的方式，第一步就是工作分配。我们获取输入，并想出某种策略，将其分配给一组线程。
Yeah? In the case of these array language operations and things like C++ ranges, we have some input sequence or data of length n. And typically what we do is we take that n and we divide it up equally or as equally as possible among m threads. Now, when we have something like filter or chunk by that is going to change the shape of that original in inputs that changes it in a way that is not cannot be known a priori then we have to discover
是吗？在这些数组语言操作和C++范围之类的事情中，我们有一些长度为n的输入序列或数据。通常我们做的是取n，并尽可能平均地分配给m个线程。现在，当我们有像filter或chunk by这样会改变原始输入形状的操作时，这种改变方式是无法预先知道的，所以我们必须并行发现
the change of the shape in parallel. So if it's something like stride, right, where we say we're going to take every third element, we can simply handle that during work distribution. If we have something like stride, we can just say, okay, we're just going to pretend that the input's actually you know n divided by three and then we're going to split up that n divided by three input among the m threads that we have yeah that makes sense and like likewise for chunk if we have like chunk three but if we have chunk by, we don't know what the size of those groups are going to be.
形状的变化。所以如果是像stride（步长）这样的操作，对吧，我们说我们要取每第三个元素，我们可以简单地在工作分配期间处理它。如果我们有像stride这样的操作，我们可以直接说，好吧，我们假装输入实际上是n除以3，然后我们将那个n除以3的输入分配给m个线程，是的，这说得通。对于chunk也是一样，如果我们有像chunk 3这样的操作。但如果我们有chunk by，我们不知道这些组的大小会是多少。
We don't know how many we're going to have. In the same way that with filter, we don't know how many elements we're going to have on the other side. So we can't divide it up evenly among the threads. We have to, in fact, part of the thing that we're paralyzing is the non-trivial computation of the reshaping. In the case of the filter, the non-trivial computation is applying the predicate, and likewise in chunk by. So, but we still have to do work distribution. And if we can't compute a priori how the shape is going to change then we must do work distribution based upon that original in elements of input and so every thread is going to get n divided by m pieces of work okay i think i'm following still i don't see how anything
我们不知道会有多少组。就像filter一样，我们不知道另一边会有多少元素。所以我们不能在线程之间平均分配。事实上，我们正在并行化的部分就是重塑的非平凡计算。在filter的情况下，非平凡计算是应用谓词，chunk by也是一样。但是我们仍然必须进行工作分配。如果我们不能预先计算形状将如何改变，那么我们必须基于原始的n个输入元素进行工作分配，所以每个线程都会得到n除以m的工作量。好吧，我想我还在跟上，但我还是没看出这和丢弃有什么关系。
has had to do with dropping yet though right so for something like chunk by at least on a platform like a gpu platform we don't want to create new threads. We want to figure out the chunks and then we want to like create those chunks and then continue processing the rest of this pipeline of operations after the chunk by with that same group of threads. So like if we have like chunk by, like pipe transform, we want to figure out what those chunks are and we want to apply, we want to with those same groups of threads,
对吧，所以对于像chunk by这样的操作，至少在GPU这样的平台上，我们不想创建新线程。我们想找出块，然后创建这些块，然后用同一组线程继续处理chunk by之后的管道操作。所以如果我们有像chunk by，然后是pipe transform，我们想找出那些块是什么，并且我们想用同一组线程，
we want to have them apply the transform function. So if we've got M threads, each of which are given in initial pieces of work, then we need to figure out, like, which one of these threads are going to need to call this transform function. Because it's not going to be every thread. I mean, it could be. You could have a chunk by function that makes everything into a chunk of one element. That's the limit for the most number of chunks that you can have. But let's assume that that's not the case,
我们想让他们应用转换函数。所以如果我们有M个线程，每个线程都被分配了初始的工作片段，那么我们需要找出，哪些线程需要调用这个转换函数。因为不会是每个线程。我是说，也可能是。你可以有一个chunk by函数，把所有东西都变成一个元素的块。那是你能拥有的最大块数。但让我们假设不是那样，
that we're going to end up with fewer chunks than we had initial elements. In that sense, so then in that situation, when we get to that transform operation, after the chunking operation, some of the threads that own some of those original input items, some of those threads are not going to participate in the transform operation. Because we don't need all of them to participate. We don't have in chunks. We have some number less than in chunks. And so we need some way for those threads to decide which, you know, who's going to do which, which of these original in pieces of work that we were given are no longer valid. And that process of deciding who's gonna handle the chunks is very similar to how we
我们最终得到的块数会比初始元素少。在这种情况下，当我们到达转换操作时，在分块操作之后，一些拥有原始输入项的线程，其中一些线程将不会参与转换操作。因为我们不需要所有线程都参与。我们没有n个块。我们拥有的块数少于n。所以我们需要某种方式让这些线程决定，谁来做哪一个，我们被分配的原始n个工作片段中，哪些不再有效。而那个决定谁来处理块的过程，非常类似于我们
parallelize removal now let's talk about the algorithm that i was working on last week and was excited to talk about oh we can't move on yet we're not moving on we're talking about how do you implement chunk buy in parallel. And one second. Hang on. I will be right back. All right, well, Bryce is over there. I mean, I'm not fully buying what he's selling, folks. First of all, I'd like an example of the transform operation that he says we're applying to each chunk that has resulted from the chunk by.
现在并行化移除的方式。让我们谈谈我上周一直在研究的算法，我很兴奋能谈谈它。哦，我们还不能继续。我们还没继续。我们正在谈论如何并行实现chunk by。等一下。我马上回来。好吧，Bryce在那边。我是说，伙计们，我并不完全买他的账。首先，我想要一个他说的应用到chunk by产生的每个块上的转换操作的例子。
I'm saying if you have chunk by pipe transform. Yeah, that's what I just said. It's just an arbitrary chunk by followed by transform. Okay. What do you mean? Are you saying do you want an example of how you would use Shung-Fai in a pipeline? I can come up with a ton of examples, but the reason why I'm asking for one is what you're thinking. Here's one.
我说的是如果你有chunk by pipe transform。是的，我刚才就是这么说的。这只是一个任意的chunk by后面跟着一个transform。好吧。你什么意思？你是说你想要一个关于如何在管道中使用chunk by的例子吗？我可以举出一堆例子，但我之所以要一个例子，是因为你在想什么。这是一个。
Here's one. Take an input of text and compute the average length of every word that was i literally as soon as you said the text thing that's where i thought you were going so this is an example where everything that bryce said doesn't need to apply because every thread will get used an example like where you are doing a reduction this this is one of the easiest. You're going to have to move closer because I'm going to have to read from my computer. Well, now I'm recording a podcast. A local friend, Phineas of the pod.
这是一个。获取一段文本输入，并计算每个单词的平均长度。我刚才一听到你说文本，我就想到你要说这个了。所以这是一个Bryce所说的一切都不适用的例子，因为每个线程都会被用到。一个你正在做归约（reduction）的例子，这是最简单的。你得靠近点，因为我得读我电脑上的东西。好吧，现在我在录播客。播客的一位当地朋友，Phineas。
Why is it a friend of the pod? He's a friend of mine. Has just messaged me. And now we've got to reply back. Recording pod right now. Good luck editing this section, Connor. Maybe we'll just leave it in. No, you better not.
为什么他是播客的朋友？他是我的朋友。刚给我发了消息。现在我们得回复。正在录播客。祝你剪辑这段内容好运，Connor。也许我们直接留着。不，你最好别。
We'll reply in a few minutes. Do you think I'm going to be done with you in a few minutes? Yeah, well, it could mean more than that. minutes and you think i'm gonna be done with you in a few minutes yeah well that's you know it could mean more than that anyways um so because basically you've got your chunk by and you're chunking by uh spaces which is going to give you words there's maybe something a little bit more complicated than that and then your transform is a ranges colon stood colon colon ranges colon colon distance which you can think of as a reduction you definitely can just do that it doesn't matter if like where your blocks are split
我们几分钟后再回。你觉得我几分钟就能搞定你吗？是的，好吧，这可能意味着更多。几分钟，你觉得我几分钟就能搞定你吗？是的，好吧，你知道，这可能意味着更多。总之，嗯，所以基本上你有你的chunk by，你按空格分块，这会给你单词，可能还有比这更复杂的东西，然后你的转换是ranges::std::ranges::distance，你可以把它看作一个归约。你绝对可以这样做，这没关系，即使你的块在哪里分割
you know that was across a word because you can just handle that you know oh the length of this string is three and the length of this string is two that was across a border you just add them together there's no threads that weren't doing work. Like, so in that example, anytime basically where you're... How are there not any threads doing work? Because all of them are doing, are calculating the length of the elements
你知道，那是跨越了一个单词，因为你可以处理它，你知道，哦，这个字符串的长度是3，这个字符串的长度是2，那是跨越了边界，你只需要把它们加在一起。没有线程没在干活。所以在这个例子中，任何时候基本上你都在……怎么会没有线程在干活？因为它们都在做，都在计算块中元素的长度。
that are in your chunk. Why would any thread not need to do that computation? Okay, let's say that we have... Well, now he's changing the example. See, and this is why... No, we're going to use the same example. Let's say that we've got some input string of text that has four words in it.
为什么会有线程不需要做那个计算？好吧，假设我们有……好吧，现在他在换例子。看，这就是为什么……不，我们要用同一个例子。假设我们有一个包含四个单词的输入字符串。
Okay. And let's say that it has in total... Each word is like four characters long. There's a space after each one. So we have 20 characters total in the input. Okay. So we spin up, let's say 20 threads, each of which is given a single character. And then we apply.
好吧。假设它总共有……每个单词大约四个字符长。每个单词后面有一个空格。所以输入总共有20个字符。好吧。所以我们启动，假设20个线程，每个线程被分配一个字符。然后我们应用。
What? How is every thread given a single character how are you able to it's an example connor but how are you supposed to calculate like each thread needs at least more than one character every every thread is responsible for one character it's it's looking at adjacent characters because that's how chunk by works but it's computing the answer for the predicate for one character every thread is answer for the predicate for one character. Every thread is checking the predicate for one character. And yes, that may require it to look at a second character, but that's not the character that that thread is responsible for.
什么？怎么每个线程只分配一个字符？你是怎么能……这只是个例子，Connor。但你怎么能计算，每个线程至少需要一个以上的字符。每个线程负责一个字符，它在看相邻的字符，因为chunk by就是这样工作的，但它是在为这一个字符计算谓词的答案。每个线程都在为这一个字符检查谓词。是的，这可能需要它看第二个字符，但那不是那个线程负责的字符。
So you have 20 threads, each of which is going to run the predicate and determine whether this is the end of a word. Right? Okay. Sure. and determine whether this is the end of a word, right? Okay. So are you somehow claiming that all 20 of those threads are going to run the transform function that calls distance on each one of those chunks? No. Only four of those threads are going to run distance on the chunk because there's only four words.
所以你有20个线程，每个线程都要运行谓词并确定这是否是一个单词的结尾。对吧？好吧。确定这是否是一个单词的结尾，对吧？好吧。所以你是在声称那20个线程都会运行那个调用distance的转换函数吗？不。只有四个线程会运行distance，因为只有四个单词。
There aren't 20 words. there's only four words. There aren't 20 words. There's only four words. How do you figure out the length of the word now that every thread only has one character? There has to be some like thread communication stuff now and all the threads need to communicate. So that's work. Yes.
没有20个单词。只有四个单词。没有20个单词。只有四个单词。既然每个线程只有一个字符，你怎么算出单词的长度？现在必须有一些线程通信的东西，所有线程都需要通信。所以那是工作。是的。
But I mean, how else would we divide this problem? How do we have the threads communicate? What is the number one most common communication mechanism that we use? Scans. And we perhaps haven't talked about this before. Scan is not an algorithm. Scan is a communication mechanism. Scan and a non-commutative reduction where information goes from left to right are communication mechanisms. They are synchronization primitives for threads to communicate to threads that are later in the computation.
但我意思是，我们还能怎么分配这个问题？我们怎么让线程通信？我们使用的最常见的通信机制是什么？扫描（Scan）。我们之前可能没谈过这个。Scan不是一个算法。Scan是一种通信机制。Scan和非交换归约（其中信息从左到右传递）是通信机制。它们是线程与后续计算中的线程进行通信的同步原语。
Connor, put your phone away. Put your phone away. You just got invited though, so... You put your phone away. Now my girlfriend's calling me at the same time. Yeah, well, you know what? Priorities, buddy, priorities. How'd.
Connor，把手机收起来。把手机收起来。你刚被邀请了，所以……你把手机收起来。现在我女朋友也在同时给我打电话。是的，好吧，你知道吗？优先级，伙计，优先级。怎么了。
Hey, sweetie. She can't talk right now. Sorry, we're recording a podcast. Did you hear that? Oh. Did you hear that? Okay, that's my cue to go. Okay, call me later. Sure. Do you hear that? Okay. That's my cue to go. Okay. Call me later?
嘿，亲爱的。她现在不能说话。抱歉，我们在录播客。你听到了吗？哦。你听到了吗？好吧，这是我该走的时候了。好吧，晚点打给我。当然。你听到了吗？好吧。这是我该走的时候了。好吧。晚点打给我？
Sure. Do you want to say anything to all the listeners? No. All right. We're moving on. We're moving on. All right. I'll call you later.
当然。你想对所有听众说点什么吗？不。好吧。我们继续。我们继续。好吧。我晚点打给你。
Okay. All right. Bye. Okay. I will read you a little bit. You got to move a little closer so I can read this from this document I've been working on. Move the mic a little closer. Stop texting your girlfriend.
好吧。好吧。再见。好吧。我会读给你一点。你得靠近点，这样我才能从我一直在研究的这份文档里读出来。把麦克风靠近点。别给你女朋友发短信了。
I'm texting Phineas. We're having dinner with him later. We're having dinner with him later. I don't care whether you're texting Phineas. I don't care who you're texting. Okay. You and I, I don't know if we've talked about this before, but I think it's not particularly relevant. So this is from my little document on how we parallelize ranges and parallel algorithms.
我在给Phineas发短信。我们晚点要和他吃晚饭。我们晚点要和他吃晚饭。我不在乎你在给Phineas发短信。我不在乎你在给谁发短信。好吧。你和我，我不知道我们之前有没有谈过这个，但我认为这没什么特别的关联。所以这是来自我关于我们如何并行化范围和并行算法的小文档。
Can I ask a question? No. Okay. Certain range adapters group or combine elements in a way that cannot be trivially computed a priori. And that's how I think about chunk by. I think about it as combining elements together. And that, I think, is the correct mindset to lead us to the parallel algorithm for chunk by. These adapters reduce the size of the input sequence. When considering how to parallelize them, we should think of them as both transforming and removing elements.
我可以问个问题吗？不。好吧。某些范围适配器以一种无法预先平凡计算的方式对元素进行分组或组合。这就是我思考chunk by的方式。我把它看作是将元素组合在一起。我认为，这是引导我们找到chunk by并行算法的正确思维方式。这些适配器减少了输入序列的大小。在考虑如何并行化它们时，我们应该把它们看作既转换又移除元素。
A parallel implementation of these adapters must do two things. Also, is this your paper that got published? A parallel implementation of these adapters must do two things. Compute the groupings, which requires some form of summation, discard whichever of the m initial elements per execution agent do not represent one of the groupings. So the computation of those groupings can be implemented by inserting some sort of in-place scan preprocessing pass. Because I don't know that we've talked about how you implement like
这些适配器的并行实现必须做两件事。另外，这是你发表的那篇论文吗？这些适配器的并行实现必须做两件事。计算分组，这需要某种形式的求和，丢弃每个执行代理中不代表分组的m个初始元素中的那些。所以这些分组的计算可以通过插入某种原地扫描预处理过程来实现。因为我不知道我们是否谈过你如何实现像
copy if in parallel before in this podcast have we nope oh well maybe we're gonna talk about that next but just take it we've only got 10 minutes take it as a given that we can implement copy if in terms of scan we have talked about that at least that copy if is implemented in terms of scan has come up. So then my paper says, as discussed in the non-trivial removal section. What are you doing to the mic, man? Stop. You're making me. As discussed in the non-trivial removal section,
copy if并行化之前在这个播客里谈过吗？没有。哦，好吧，也许我们下次会谈到，但只要假设我们只有10分钟，假设我们可以用扫描来实现copy if。我们确实谈过copy if是用扫描实现的。所以我的论文说，正如在非平凡移除部分讨论的那样。你在对麦克风做什么，伙计？停下。你让我。正如在非平凡移除部分讨论的那样，
the removal of elements can be done by inserting an in-place COPYIF preprocessing pass. And COPYIF can be implemented. Stop squeezing the mic like that. And COPYIF can be implemented like that and copy if can be i'm starting this part over as discussed in the non-trivial removal section the removal of elements can be done by inserting an in-place copy if pre-processing pass and copy if can be implemented with a scan so for our purposes which aren't particularly worried about ranges, my point there is copy if can be implemented with a scan. Hang on, I'm not done yet.
元素的移除可以通过插入一个原地COPYIF预处理过程来完成。而COPYIF可以实现。别那样挤压麦克风。而COPYIF可以实现，而copy if可以——我重新开始这一部分。正如在非平凡移除部分讨论的那样，元素的移除可以通过插入一个原地copy if预处理过程来完成，而copy if可以用扫描来实现。所以对于我们的目的，我们并不特别担心范围，我的观点是copy if可以用扫描来实现。等一下，我还没说完。
I'll tell you when you can talk. So filtering operations, removing operations like copy if, can be implemented with a scan. Now, these two operations of computing the groupings and needing to remove elements can be combined into a single scan-based preprocessing pass that both computes the groupings and removes all but one element per grouping. Okay. Have we ever – are you – implement copy if in terms of scan? Wait.
我会告诉你什么时候可以说话。所以过滤操作，像copy if这样的移除操作，可以用扫描来实现。现在，计算分组和需要移除元素这两个操作可以合并成一个基于扫描的预处理过程，它既计算分组，又移除每个分组中除一个元素之外的所有元素。好吧。我们有没有——你是——用扫描实现copy if？等等。
Can I ask questions now? No. You can implement copy if in terms of scan. What is happening? I need to ask a question. Yeah. Okay. Can I ask one?
我现在可以问问题了吗？不。你可以用扫描实现copy if。发生了什么？我需要问个问题。是的。好吧。我可以问一个吗？
Yeah. I'd like to ask two, but I'll settle for one. It better be a time. It's definitely about what you just said so are you it it hurts my soul to hear that like the size of the input sequence is decreasing because in a sense that is true because i remember you saying this in a meeting once that like when a range goes through a cut operation or a grouping operation as you call it and it becomes a range of ranges now the size of technically the outer range has decreased from whatever 20 to 4 yeah we agree but like to say that the size of the input is decreasing like all those elements are still
是的。我想问两个，但我问一个就行。最好是关于时间的。这绝对是关于你刚才说的，所以你——听到输入序列的大小在减小，我的灵魂都在痛，因为在某种意义上那是真的，因为我记得你在会议上说过，当一个范围经过切割操作或你所说的分组操作，变成一个范围的范围时，现在技术上外部范围的大小已经从20减少到4了，我们同意，但说输入的大小在减小，所有那些元素仍然
there they're just like right but but they've just been inner range of five which but this is this is a mindset that represents how we implement this physically in parallel on a massively parallel processor like a GPU. So that's what my question is. and then you end up with only four threads doing work, is that because you gave all the data of the other 16 threads to each of those four threads? Yeah. And how did you do that? With a reduction. With like a reduce by key or a scan. That was my second question is How does reduced by key work?
在那里，它们只是像——对，但它们只是变成了五个的内部范围，但这是一种代表我们在像GPU这样的大规模并行处理器上物理实现并行的方式的思维方式。所以这就是我的问题。然后你最终只有四个线程在工作，这是因为你把其他16个线程的所有数据都给了那四个线程中的每一个吗？是的。你是怎么做到的？用归约。用像reduce by key或scan。这是我的第二个问题，reduce by key是怎么工作的？
We're going to get there. We're going to get there. How do we implement copy if in parallel? Copy if in parallel. I would imagine well, I wouldn't imagine. If I had to do it, I would so copy if, for those that don't
我们会讲到的。我们会讲到的。我们如何并行实现copy if？并行copy if。我想，好吧，我不会去想。如果我必须做，我会——所以copy if，对于那些不知道的人，
know, is a algorithm similar to copy but it takes a unary predicate and only copies the element uh if it satisfies that predicate and there's actually a couple different overloads that we've talked about in past episodes anyways how do we Basically do a scan on a transformed sequence representing ones and zeros that are basically corresponding to whether each element returned true for the unary predicate. You do a plus scan on that to get the resulting indices, and then you do a gather operation, and you're done. Yes. This is, well, you can look at the code now.
是一个类似于copy的算法，但它接受一个一元谓词，并且只有在元素满足该谓词时才复制它，实际上我们过去几期节目谈过几种不同的重载。总之，我们如何基本上对一个转换后的序列进行扫描，该序列代表0和1，基本上对应于每个元素是否为一元谓词返回true。你对它进行加法扫描以获得结果索引，然后你进行收集（gather）操作，你就完成了。是的。这是，好吧，你现在可以看代码了。
I will explain it in a slightly different way. To implement the naive way of implementing a scan in parallel, I'm going to describe a three-pass approach which needs two O-N vectors. So the first pass is we compute the flags. So we create a vector of flags which are just booleans except it can't be vector bool because that's broken in C++. But we have a vector of bools or flags and we do a transform where we run the predicate for each one of the input elements and we assign the results of that into this flags vector and so we have in flags one for each of the input elements and that flag is true if the predicate returned true and false otherwise
我会用稍微不同的方式解释它。要实现并行扫描的朴素方式，我将描述一个三遍法，它需要两个O-N向量。所以第一遍是我们计算标志。所以我们创建一个标志向量，它们只是布尔值，除了它不能是vector bool，因为那在C++中是坏的。但我们有一个bool向量或标志，我们做一个转换，我们为每个输入元素运行谓词，并将结果赋值到这个标志向量中，所以我们有n个标志，每个输入元素一个，如果谓词返回true，该标志为true，否则为false。
you don't even need to do that you can but it's it for the purposes of explaining it this is a bit the very simple elegant version of the sound rhythm. Then we have to build our second vector of information, which is the indices of where elements that are going to be copied are going to move to. And to do that, we scan the flags array. And we write the results of that scan into a vector of int that each element for which the predicate is true should be assigned to. And then that gather operation that Connor mentioned, in thrust we have a thing called
你甚至不需要那样做，你可以，但为了解释的目的，这是扫描算法的一个非常简单优雅的版本。然后我们必须构建我们的第二个信息向量，也就是元素将被复制到的索引。为了做到这一点，我们扫描标志数组。我们将扫描的结果写入一个int向量，每个谓词为true的元素都应该被分配到那里。然后那个Connor提到的收集操作，在Thrust中我们有一个东西叫
thrust gather, but we don't in standard C++. But it's pretty easy to implement. The way I have it written here is I've got a foreach over a zip of the original input, the flags array, and the indices array. And so the function that's passed to this foreach, it's going to take three inputs, an element, a flag, and an index. And what that function does is if the flag is true, then it will assign to in the output the element's value. And then to compute the range of how large the output that you've created is, you just take the last index from the scan that you did. And that is the size of the output.
thrust gather，但在标准C++中我们没有。但它很容易实现。我这里写的方式是我对原始输入、标志数组和索引数组的zip进行了一个foreach。所以传递给这个foreach的函数，它将接受三个输入，一个元素，一个标志，和一个索引。那个函数所做的是，如果标志为true，那么它将把元素的值赋给输出。然后要计算你创建的输出有多大，你只需要取你做的扫描的最后一个索引。那就是输出的大小。
And after that explanation, I realized that the gather that I was referring to, I was being a little lackadaisical, a little loose. I should have said what I specifically meant was a gather if, which is what you just described. Yes.
在那段解释之后，我意识到我提到的收集，我有点漫不经心，有点松散。我应该说我具体指的是gather if，也就是你刚才描述的那个。是的。
All right, folks. Well, that's the end of the episode. No, it's not. It is not in no way, shape, or form the end of the episode. You hear that, folks? That's the sound of Bryce's mic not next to his mic. Well, because this thing is, this is not the end of the episode. Okay, Connor.
好了，伙计们。好吧，那是这期节目的结尾。不，不是。它绝不是这期节目的结尾。你听到了吗，伙计们？那是Bryce的麦克风不在他麦克风旁边的声音。好吧，因为这个东西，这不是节目的结尾。好吧，Connor。
Be sure to check these show notes either in your podcast app or at adspthepodcast.com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode as well as a link to a github discussion where you can leave thoughts comments and questions thanks for listening we hope you enjoyed and have a great day low quality high quantity that is the tagline of our podcast it's not the tagline our tagline is chaos with sprinkles of information There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请务必在你的播客应用中或在adspthepodcast.com上查看这些节目笔记，获取我们今天提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个GitHub讨论的链接，你可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。感谢收听，我们希望你喜欢，祝你有美好的一天。低质量、高数量，这就是我们播客的口号。这不是口号，我们的口号是带有信息碎片的混乱。这期节目还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来留下评论。